à ces motards pour visiter son père
gravement malade en chine razieh
mammouth une citoyenne canadienne
d'origine ouigours a fait une demande de
visa en 2010 est convoqué à l'ambassade
de chine à ottawa elle a subi un long
interrogatoire
bombardé de questions personnelles au
sujet de sa parenté et celle de son
conjoint de ses voyages à l'étranger et
même de ses collègues de travail
j'étais vraiment avoir peur et paie une
lourde ont trouvé finalement même son
démon du coût du travail
selon une fuite de documents
confidentiels du gouvernement chinois
obtenu par le consortium international
des journalistes d' enquête
ces informations glanées depuis les
ambassades viennent nourrir le
redoutable appareil de surveillance qui
a instauré la chine dans la région de
xinjiang au nom de la lutte
anti-terrorisme pékin exerce un grand
contrôle sur la population ouïghoure une
minorité musulmane selon l'onu plus d'un
million d'entre eux ont été internés
dans des camps d'endoctrinement
on est en train de mettre en place une
société dystopique alain georges orwell
des systèmes de surveillance par caméra
reconnaissance faciale la mise en place
de
gps qui trace les mouvements des
véhicules privés lorsque des étrangers
d'origine ouigours se rendent en chine
ils font l'objet d'une surveillance de
tous les instants comme l'a constaté
razia mammouth lors d'un repas dans un
restaurant pendant son court séjour à
yining sa ville d'origine du troisième
ils ont resté à côté de nous tout au
long de manger là où finalement aussi
qu'est qui était le circuit à jour de
sécurité
et puis on a eu peur on n'a même pas
fini notre notre manger on est parti et
après partout et notre surveillance
il ya hélas de police autour de nos ce
document secret du gouvernement chinois
de juin 2017 contient des statistiques
de surveillance précise sur les
étrangers d'origine ouigours présent en
chine qui doivent être examinées par les
préfectures
on y indique qu'il y avait cinq
canadiens ça veut dire qu'il y avait
déjà une surveillance importante sur les
ouigours à l'étranger ce qui est déjà
quelque part inquiétant parce que ce
sont des citoyens non chinois c'est des
citoyens canadiens tueur que ghazi a
restreint ses contacts avec sa famille
en chine et ne parle jamais de chose
importante c'est que pékin écoute et
pourrait envoyer ses proches dans un
camp d'internement à la moindre critique
du régime